of the european commission ursula forban
lang is participating in our today's
meeting let's welcome mrs president
madam president
ukraine participating in this meeting
are the president the prime minister of
prime minister of ukraine
denis schmiegel and the members of the
cabinet of ministers of ukraine let's
welcome the government of ukraine
the parliament members of ukraine their
guests
for the diplomats
present with us is mighty massacres the
eu eu ambassador to ukraine ambassadors
of the eu
eu states and the ambassador of the
austrian republic
please welcome the diplomats
following our good traditions we shall
start our work with singing the national
anthem of ukraine
oh
hold up
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
ukraine this is the fifth month of the
aggression of russian federation against
ukraine and uh in response to granting
ukraine
the eu member eu candidate member states
the uh the enemy has intensified the
shelling of the civilians and the most
terrible thing is that the children are
dying barbarian
shelling of criminalization
alive and other cities this support this
concerns the fact that russia is not to
be placed among the civilized world and
the a as a result of the missile
swelling today
according to the latest information 18
our citizens and 31
died and 31 are casual are wounded
ukrainian people are invincible i i'm
asking you to stand in the minute of
silence to pay tribute to ukrainian
citizens who died as a result of
aggression and shelling and to pay
tribute to the memory of ukrainian
defenders
it gives me a very great pleasure to
give the floor to
the president of ukraine volodymer
alexandrovic zelensky
thank you very much
the
dia dia chairman of the performer of
ukraine dear prime minister of ukraine
dia
parliament members of ukraine dear all
guests present in this session room the
new history of ukraine and the eu has
started we are not close we are together
now
we are we are close neighbors
we are not the close neighbors but we
are one european families with
shared
values and shared faith these are not
the words these are not declaration this
is not the expectation or political hope
this is already legally fixed status
ukraine
ukraine has received the status of
of the candidate states to you
membership
115 days
lasted from
giving the application and response of
the eu this is the record short time we
were very very together in order to act
together in order to defend ourselves
and we were defending together working
together to defend our land we were not
stopping for any second before the eu
council has passed the positive decision
and we will not stop for a second before
we receive our victory the victory of
ukraine
we are aware that the eu integration for
of ukraine
this is
this will give
this will give generations of ukraine
the better life based on the best human
values this is the owner this is the
responsibility for all of us to
participate in the implementation of
european aspirations of our state what
is 115 days a lot of things were taking
place in those days
hundreds of negotiations meetings
concerts different rallies to support
ukraine and our candidate status
hundreds of approved decisions hundreds
of updated procedures and thousands
thousands of perfectly filled out
questionnaires which we have received
from the eu commission all this was not
easy but we have done it and
congratulations we did it
we have created
extremely solid foundation which will
not be ruined by anybody
and which will be used as the foundation
for european uh our european future our
european future is our may transformed
into our current days ukraine is
fighting for the future in order to live
in the free european family ukrainians
have the weapons in their hands in order
to protect the independence and safety
and security of each our person in order
for ukrainian warnings to start not so
tragically as started today's
morning with the missile's attack on
other center that's a region
today's morning started with a lot of
victims we want the mornings of ukraine
to become as peaceful as the mornings of
each european capital in the 21st
century i want very much that everybody
who is taking their official positions
in ukraine now would
work for european choice of ukraine as
the
fighter for our state all of us we need
to prepare our state to
for the beginning of negotiation of eu
membership as intensely as we were
preparing the decisions on the uh status
of canada today in this
session the
uh the flag of eu will be brought in
into this room into this session room of
the virgo narada of ukraine and this
must not be just nearly beautiful symbol
or gesture
this must be
the symbol of our task
the task for all of us for all branches
of power in ukraine for us to avoid any
pauses or any delays in our work for
each decision which is required for
ukrainian for eu path of ukraine to be
passed in time and these must be the
decisions which will be positively felt
by ukrainian society ukrainian families
ukrainian people
eu membership
is not geopolitics or implementation of
some political aspirations these are
specific things
specific advantages which are bringing
benefits to the life of each person in
ukraine each company in ukraine each
state institution in ukraine or recently
we have introduced visa free
transportation at the aerial visa free
transportation we have received maximum
access to european market without
quarters or customs we join the european
energy grid now we can export
electricity to the eu member states
this
is the
revolutionary decision for our economy
and our state and we are waiting for
customs with the free regime and digital
visa free regime for ukraine to join the
program digital europe we need to
accelerate the industrial visa-free
regime and of course we need to make
decision about cancelling the roaming
fee for ukraine
between ukraine and the eu states on
permanent basis
european paths
these are the decisions
which are enhancing our state and each
of you because all these decisions
create the opportunities for all europe
to
to
implementation of ukrainian potential
makes europe stronger stronger together
with ukraine a lot of decisions will
depend on the vergna narada of ukraine
on each parliament member of ukraine on
how
well are you the parliament members are
ready to work on this decision and so
already are you to coordinate your work
with the government of the president of
our diplomats the association agreement
between ukraine and eu has been
implemented by 63 percent
37
these are the tasks for all of us for
all our state but
you
dear parliament members you need to
develop
and defend and pass dozens dozens of
very important draft loss and laws this
will not be easy but there is no
alternative to that
and even if you
even if you know that there will be not
a cl your some of your decisions will
not be uploaded but this decision is
required and needed in order to go
through this
difficult and important part of ukraine
you
must pass such decisions
today we are signing joint statement
which is a signal of unity of all
branches of power
and the evidence of our determination to
achieve the strategic goal of ukraine
which is their full
membership in the european union
signing of this statement has the same
importance as the importance of signing
this application for joining to eu on
the fifth day of the war and it took us
115 days to receive the status of
candidates state to the eu membership
our path to the full membership should
not be lasting for dozens of years we
must go through these paths as quickly
as possible and it depends on us how
quickly we shall move we must do our
work perfect in order to enable our
friends in the eu in the same very fast
and consolidated fashion and manner to
approve yet another historic decision
we shall sign
and now i would like to ask her
the
chairman of the behold narada of ukraine
and the dear prime minister of ukraine
and now please upload
i want to thank
all european people each
european leaders who supported the
candidacy of our state to the eu
membership i want to thank them very
much indeed
during such a short time frame
[Music]
this is the record thing but all these
meetings and negotiations
were very topical and very well thought
through sometimes they were challenging
i want to thank all of you thank all
those present in this session all
members of the cabinet of ministers of
ukraine thank you very much
i want to thank each
each
person
and
each person
knows
that it was a difficult difficult and
challenging work which resulted in
success and the great personal
contribution was made by the great
friends of ukraine
who
are and who will continue to be our
friends this is the president of the eu
council charlie michelle
the president of the european commission
ursula thunderline
today i have the honor to
to make the presentation and
speech in the virgo narada of ukraine
mrs ursula mrs upsell i want to thank
you once again for your leadership
in the
building of this uh
of this
powerful historical relationship between
ukraine and europe and this relationship
is a new history for ukraine and you
european history joined european history
and ukraine glory to ukraine and the
floor is given to mrs ursula ponderlar
thank you so much
thank you so much president zelinski
dear vladimir
chairman stefan shook prime minister
miguel de adenis
members of the government and honorable
members of the rada
duja diacoyou
thank you so much for inviting me to
address this special session
just days ago on constitution day
president zelensky you said
that your victory is not far off
and of course bhuti's putin's army is
still killing your brothers and sisters
they continue occupying your land
stealing your grain
and bombing your cities
you are fighting back bravely
and europe will stand up with ukraine as
long as it takes
we will not rest
until you prevail
your brave soldiers on the front line
are making ultimate sacrifices
to defend the soil of ukraine and its
people
and behind the lines
there are countless other ukrainians
working to support this national
endeavor
and they all hope for a brighter future
for their country
this is a courageous generation
on the march towards their vision
their vision of a free ukraine that is
part of a democratic europe
and i have them clearly in my mind
as i speak to you today
you have kept your state and your
democracy up and running against all
odds
i saw it with my own eyes
after coming to keefe twice since the
beginning of the war
you have kept the parliament open
even in the darkest days
when bombs fell on keefe
and you had to build barricades to
protect the radar
ukraine fired its application for
membership in the european union only
days after the russian invasion
and you managed to provide us with all
the necessary information
in record time
to put forward a strong opinion
we in the european institutions work day
and night to support you
but it is your effort
that got the work done
you mobilized not only your institutions
but the best energies in your country
you reached out to thousands of experts
from civil society and academia
to showcase everything ukraine has
achieved since the revolution of dignity
and because of this effort
you have gained the endorsement
and the respect of all eu member states
this is a significant sign of trust
ukraine now has a very clear european
perspective
and ukraine is candidate country to join
the european union
something that seemed almost
unimaginable just five months ago
so today
is first and foremost
a moment to celebrate this historic
milestone
a victory of determination and resolve
and a victory for the whole movement
that started eight years ago on the
maidan
you have come such a long way since 2014
you have chosen firmly to be a democracy
and to live under the rule of law
and this choice ukraine has already made
for itself for its own sake
mr president you once told me
that everything that ukraine would do
for eu membership
it would do anyway
because that is the modern and
prosperous ukraine you want it to be
and the next steps are within your reach
but they will require hard work
determination
and above all unity of purpose
today the international community is
mobilizing
to support your efforts to rebuild your
beautiful country
next monday together with president
zielenski and prime minister miguel
i will participate in the lugano
conference
for the reconstruction of ukraine
your european path
and the reconstruction of the country
will go hand in hand
ukraine will be in the lead
massive investments will have to come
but to maximize their impact
and to foster business confidence
investments will have to be coupled
with a new wave of reforms
and you have determined your reform
agenda and you have already made
important progress
take the fight against corruption
preventing and combating corruption has
been particularly high on your agenda
since the revolution of dignity
you have created an impressive
anti-corruption machine
but now
these institutions needs teeth
and the right people in senior posts
the new head of the specialized
anti-corruption prosecutor's office
and the new director of the national
anti-corruption bureau of ukraine should
be appointed as soon as possible
or take your plans to reform the
constitutional court
legislation is needed for selection
procedures for judges
in line with the recommendations of the
venice commission
institutions must come to life
so that they can deliver on the
aspirations of your people
or think about the excessive influence
of oligarchs on the economy
today ukraine is the only country
in europe's eastern partnership
to have adopted a law
to break the oligarchs grip on your
economy and political life
and i commend you for that
now you have to focus on the
implementation of this law
in a legally sound manner
taken into account the forthcoming
opinion of the venice commission
a media law should also be adopted
one that aligns ukraine's legislation
with current eu standards and empowers
the independent media regulator
in some honorable members
many of the laws and the institutions
you need are already in place
now is the time to translate rules and
bodies
into positive enduring change
of course reforms always take time
that's how our democracies work
they need constant commitment and
dedication
and for instance
no one expects ukraine
to fill in all posts in your new
institutions
while so many of your best and brightest
are fighting on the front
but ukraine's democracy must be kept on
the right track
and you have already shown
that you can pass important laws even as
the war still rages on
and make every day count
you know the work that lies ahead better
than anyone else
the word rada
means counsel
and counsel means collective wisdom
i am confident
that you will put your collective wisdom
at the service of ukraine
when it comes to reform and to the
future of your country
so today i come here with a very simple
message
there's a long road ahead
but europe
will be at your side
every step of the way
for as long as it takes
from these dark days of war
until the moment
you cross the door
that leads into our european union
i believe in ukraine's european future
and the reason is simple
the reason is the tenacity of the
ukrainian people
your resolve
your passion for europe
your desire to live the european dream
in your beautiful country
and as president zielenski said in his
first speech in front of this parliament
and i
quote europe is not somewhere else
europe is here
in your mind
and when europe is in your mind
then europe will come to your country
too end of quote
it is your country
it is your future
and only you can make it happen
you are the ones who can change this
country for good
and this
will be your ultimate victory
a free and prosperous and vibrant
ukraine
a sovereign ukraine that is finally
reunited with our european family
slava ukraine
thank you mr president thank you madam
president uh the we have parliament
members of ukraine be a guest of the
home of ukraine
we aim the full-fledged membership in
the eu we understand that candidate
status does not necessarily mean
immediate access we have a difficult way
ahead but we shall go through it with
success ukraine is europe sound that uh
a thousand times these days and this
makes a lot of sense because right now
we are defending not only ukraine from
this enemy but we are defending the
whole ukraine because europe we are
defending the free the right to freedom
the right to sovereignty ukrainian
parliament had a dream for uh to receive
from the eu
the clear legal definition of candidacy
and the brand of eu flag to be
brought in into the
meeting session room of the virgo
narrator of ukraine i am asking the
national guard of ukraine please
bring in the flag of the european union
in to the session auditorium of the
virgo
rada of ukraine
you
glory to ukraine glory to the heroes the
members of the ukrainian parliament it
seems to me the colors are mexican
and this sense is matching
let's dear colleagues let's thank the
president of ukraine dimmer zelensky
let's thank
the president of the european commission
ursula from the land let's thank the
ambassadors of the eu member states for
their participation in today's ceremony
of bringing in the flag of the eu in
toward the
session auditorium of the home narrator
of ukraine thank you very much for your
contribution and your presence
your colleagues dear colleagues
we continue our work we shall start our
work with uh
with
wishing happy birthday to our colleagues
parliament the members
miss
the
the birthday is celebrated by the
parliament members from
[Music]
you